ah l'amour bonjour tout le monde je suis
en pleine forme pour jouer avec vous
aujourd'hui
ouais et je suis tout propre en ce
moment ma tante adélaïde m'en vois tous
les jours un cadeau avant-hier j'ai eu
un non choix savons parfumés aux anchois
des tropiques
hier un flacon de bain moussant à la
framboise
j'ai hâte de savoir ce que je vais
recevoir demain siège au 15 mai reste
c'est inadmissible ce faire les mains
dans les poches
qu'est ce qui lui prend celui là ça fait
des années que je supportais pas
ridicule mais cette fois je ne
l'accepterai jamais nuageux du snob je
ne vous ai pas fait de farce à voter oui
oui mais tu ne vas pas nier
je vais pas mentir encore ou quoi aussi
je vous assure
et tu ne vas pas jurer par dessus le
marché selek à venir c'est très maigre
mais mais laissez-moi parer au moindre
des mensonges jamais oh ça alors oui
vous voulez peut-être parler du du kilo
de farine qu'on vous aviez commandés et
que j'ai remplacé par un kilo plate
c'est ça ouais je m'en souviens pas
aperçu mais ce n'est pas de cela dont je
veux parler mais je ne vous ai pas fait
d'autres farce non réfléchis bien
attendez ah oui voilà on vous avez
peut-être voulu goûter l'huile
d'arachide
quand j'avais remplacé par de l'huile de
foie de morue mais il ne s'agit pas de
deux de la farine de l'huile
tu as fait hier soir une autre farce
c'est impossible
c'est pourquoi mais parce que depuis
hier soir je ne suis pas sorti de chez
moi je viens juste me lever alors je
mets pas pu vous faire de farc commence
ce n'est pas toi qui m'as envoyé une
lettre te faisant passer pour une
comtesse qui me donnaient rendez-vous
dans le jardin à minuit sonne évidemment
autant je ne pouvais pas ne pas y aller
en compte est ce match du jeune abou
savait parfaitement qu'il n'y a pas de
comtesse dans l'île aux enfants
ah oui je sais très bien mais non
chaleur en voiture ce faire c'était un
si beau rêve on comptait dans les entend
a pâti mais le rêve est devenu un
cauchemar parce qu'ils n'avaient
personne et j'ai attrapé la grippe
je m'éclate et je suis vraiment furieux
furieuse
mon cabinet je reconnais là ton sens de
l'amitié à cette colère contre la
personne qui m'a fait cette phase ne
réchauffe un peu le coeur non non je
n'ai pas encore celui qui vous a fait la
farce que je suis furieux c'est contre
moi mais je ne comprends pas comment
comment tu peux être en colère contre
toi même parce que je suis absolument
furieux de n'avoir pas eu l'idée de
faire cette farce moi même sous os mais
qu'est ce que je vois vous êtes enrhumé
de ce coup du sort ne parlait pas mon
cher aimé j'attrape et froid cette nuit
dans le jardin aux jo je suis
sincèrement navré rogne pas de quoi
c'est vraiment très drôle
quelqu'un l'a envoyé une lettre signée
d'une comtesse
il lui donne rendez-vous à minuit dans
le jardin
c'est une bonne farce non en jeu je le
croyais mais c'est une erreur
à noter pour que monsieur ceux du snop
soit tombée malade il faut que ce soit
une farce stupide est une farce ne doit
jamais être dangereux mon cher emile
vous êtes un homme raisonnable mais
pourquoi avez-vous dit je le croyais ben
et ben casimir jeu là vous c'est c'est
moi le coupable c'est moi où je n'aurais
jamais cru que la nuit fut aussi fraîche
monsieur du snop est ce que vous me
pardonnez ah mais oui mon cher ami j'ai
été moi même un enfant quand je suis
venu voir une comtesse a donc on sait
parfaitement qu'il n'y en a pas
d'enfants dans les roseaux fort aux gens
sincèrement désolé enfin casimir me
saoul du soin des malades mais je n'ai
jamais vu personne les carnets de façon
aussi drôle hein parce que cela t'amuser
oui eh bien je vais te dire quelque
chose qui va te faire mourir de rire est
bien visible
j'adore rire oui alors eh bien là la
farine que tu as changé contre du plâtre
et et l'huile que tu a remplacé par de
l'huile de palme
et bien ce n'était pas pour moi c'est
pour cette chère julie qui veut te faire
une surprise
une surprise est d'ailleurs elle n'a pas
tardé de la porte est fait à amiens
c'est un magnifique gâteau au moins cher
et mis la roumanie ce docteur est
ralenti puisque disney a dit amr quasi
muet
bon appétit oh oui on c'est drôle
casimir casimir ohlala mais le temps
accord
je suis pressé mais nous on vient jeter
préparé un gâteau
non je n'ai pas faim pacha
non pas du tout au bon alors je suis
déçu je voulais faire une surprise donc
fait les enfants vous voulez manger du
gâteau avec moi je crois qu'il est très
bon j'ai dit venez vite trouver comment
que je sais vous allez me dire si les
bons - pour que l'horreur tant pis pour
toi casimir
voilà ce n'est pas tout il est fameux
lille il est vraiment bon au délicieux 1
la seule chose que je regrette c'est
d'en avoir fait si peu mais figure toi
qu'il ya une erreur dans la livraison au
lieu d'une huile d'arachide au
m'apporter de l'huile de foie de morue
et au lieu de farine du plâtre alors
j'ai dû faire avec ce qui me restait à
la maison
enfin il est bon casimir